[Music]
rockets now with their first possession
of the game Ryan Anderson is open and he
gets the three right back a Cornish team
is much better than you remember over
the last few years they are really well
coached and they've got a lot of rules
with guys on the roster
Anders should clean up off the capela
screen that's his second type flopping
down the baseline goes Gordon Anderson
to the corner
and it is fine seven consecutive misses
for the Rockettes reflection by Harden
its support race
and he will win it frog side but golems
is able to rotate to the corner barred
off the dribble count the basket and
he'll toe the line
Mammootty has got him locked up toward
conference at a
that's the way they like it's got a play
they've got to get out in the fast break
they got to get some shot clock down to
four
all right four three I get to guard that
[Music]
mark knocks down another triple short
for lamb
[Applause]
[Music]
rafer I know doesn't matter for him we
practice these days deep ones it's got
13 points averaging almost 16 a game on
the year as Hardy gets to the cup
rockets are outrebounding the Hornets
card goes right at bacon and that was
simply not kosher white already with 13
shots Eric Gordon part contested three
got it over Walker tough mate for James
Hart
[Applause]
hark back to that stooge kicking in the
corners I would say with time and this
throat you want to convince me here at
Vantage Hardin Anderson catches his
corner fries done well that's a
backbreaker